hey I'm Kelly Rohrbach and I'm an
actress and a model and I'm hanging out
with GQ today I'm playing a little golf
I started golfing through my dad I
started playing at a really young age he
was a really good golfer and sort of
always dragged me to the course playing
golf led me to Georgetown I played on
the women's team there and then when I
got to Georgetown I found acting so and
through acting modeling so I guess I
could say I'm here today because I've
got bad golf moments most of my most of
my teenage years I was like a 12 13 year
old girl playing with like 16
seven-year-old boys I'll be so
embarrassed if you're so nervous okay so
best golf tips I think are number one
keep your head down if you're a beginner
it's the number one rule that way you'll
always make contact and it's more fun to
put to play if you can get the ball to
go somewhere I guess right my second tip
is to hit it really nice and easy and
saw a smooth don't don't try to over hit
it for me I am visualize hitting a 3/4
swing so I don't over swing so I try to
keep the club up here because if you if
you go all the way back here you have to
you lose a lot of your momentum bringing
it back to the spot as opposed to you
here you can just drop your hands down
and then number three my dad always used
to say to me envision shutting a car
door with your hip you sort of want the
your first move to start from your hip
see coming through this and your and you
have your hands lag that's where you
get most of your energy and momentum for
chipping it's really specific like a lot
of people have different techniques that
they use for me I envisioned a spot on
the green that I wanted to land and I
just hold that spot in my mind's eye I
like there's like I said there's so many
different ways to do it but I like to
put my weight on my front foot and my
hands a little forward and just do like
a little punch so it has a nice clip to
it and has like good spin when it lands
that works for me